a Florida officer is in critical
condition after a suspect fired shots
past his own mother to hit the cop all
this after he sped off following a
traffic stop
on March 26th 25 year old Jacksonville
police officer Malik DuraCoat was shot
while responding to the suspect's home
the investigation stemmed from an
incident one week earlier on March 20th
but
body camera video shows Jacksonville
officers pull over 32-year-old tiliko
Maduro for running through a red light
come on shut the car off
apologize about what
their vehicles
yeah
yeah I got you man officers asked Maduro
where he's headed and for the vehicle's
registration where are you headed to
the girls out okay where's that at huh
I'm sorry I couldn't hear what the road
noises Castle okay do you have your
registration with you
you want to get in that for me
responding officers then explain they're
part of a task force searching for drugs
and illegal weapons any uh Firearms or
narcotics in the vehicle or anything
like that okay we're with a task force
as we're out here looking for man
there's people with a hard narcotic
stuff that's killing people and uh
illegally carried firearms
yeah I got you man it's good you know
um but that's what we're out here
looking for even though you said you
don't have anything like that in the
vehicle you might be taking a quick
check and then we get you on your way
do what
whatever reason okay
uh you said you you you're cool if we
take quick check it only takes about 30
seconds and we can get you on out of
here
sorry I can't hear what the face mask oh
okay Maduro tells the officers the car
does not belong to him and avoids
getting out it's your wife's car bro
are you able to just step out to talk to
us because I can't hear you from over
there with the face mask
what were you saying now
okay but you're operating it yeah
all right I hear you
know
nobody ever said you're a bad person
that's that's what we do out here is
that is we're looking for like Fentanyl
crack and stuff like that and then like
uh some illegally carried Farms are you
a convicted calling
you ain't got nothing to worry about
body camera video captures officers
explaining the reason for the task force
we respect the people out here too man
we just have a
we have a high crime rate in
Jacksonville I'm sure you probably heard
you live in Jacksonville right
one because they want us to take some
type of action and and
well yeah I mean we didn't we never said
we were it's then that officers become
more aggressive and asking Maduro to
search the vehicle man
I don't need her
operator
mid-conversation Maduro speeds off
dude we got your name you're gonna get
it
[Applause]
foreign
officials say the officers did not chase
after Maduro because the incident had
only been a traffic violation but one
week later on March 26th they followed
up with the investigation
officials contacted maduro's Mother
after no one answered the door she is
the woman seen in this body camera video
hey Max
Nicole
hello Nico
everybody home maduro's mother
eventually opens the door seconds later
when an officer shines a light on Maduro
inside the home he opens fire
whoa that's a big dog
maduro's mother can be heard pleading
for him to stop as officers radio for
more backup
stop stop please
[Music]
let me go
x-ray four switch one's down
investigators say no Jacksonville police
officers fired their weapons during the
incident and that Maduro died from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound right now
officer derekote is still in recovery
from his injuries reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie